hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to boogeyman I'm almost
completely over my cold or flu or
whatever it was I had and my voice is
pretty much recovered but god damn that
is loud how am I gonna be able to hear
anything
well this is not fair is that me and my
mom on the bed side over there I swear
these paintings have gotten even worse
of us to please everyone there's the
whole game instead of why is evidence
just show you fresh lines okay thanks
Oh
oh god I am in trouble oh he is like
SuperDuper active oh he is why oh god he
was halfway then oh my god back down
come on give me a breather man oh Jesus
back it up Oh God
don't do that
Oh God huh
oh god he is so much of everywhere this
guy's literally for everywhere on a lie
back off ma'am you're gonna run me out
of battery so I got a long night ahead
of me I can't I literally cannot hear
well
saw that I literally cannot hear
anything as far as auditory clues of
where he is
hey stop that either that or I can
barely hear anything
okay let's just the airplane - setting
to skitter away across the floor as
perfectly normal everything at area
traveling our ball hey stop being
perfectly normal
okay god damn it literally how would
anyone be willing to how'd every way
what are you are you a distraction
don't look at me I'm too smart to be
distracted hey that happens at the same
time like okay damn it the ball
distraction got me
I was just stricted hot was door stroke
did damn it uh-oh it's so creepy I feel
like I feel like I'm talking louder than
I normally am because I can't hear
myself when I'm talking it's like what
I'm doing the whisper challenge that I
gained here Missa hang on I gotta take
off my cold clothes now that the initial
panic is over I can deal with everything
trying to kill me all at once for ever
and actually keep it close well can I
just spin like a top
oh yeah I know it happened before he
opened the window and that's why I
became easier for him to get in through
there okay you're not gonna open my
window this show for a freak with the
time other work the back yeah
it's all I got like a 20-second battery
what a wonderful lash light you've given
me Oh sister of mine I highly doubt that
you're my sister
cuz this is some baloney
bye fight fight fight fight no no no no
no no oh this bogeyman why doesn't he
just come in and Kelly already or I mean
please don't
there's the Kushi Jew why is their goose
teased all over my window
Hey I was hell I'm dude
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead what
the hell are we smell it well how does
he knock it in that seems like something
that whoa can I just see him posing oh
so elegantly like one of my French girls
in my window I think that's what I saw
goddamn how would anyone beat the harder
night's fight back off ma could you get
the phone
there's bogeymen I'm wasting my battery
I know I am Oh God
Hey
nope
I'm gonna need a battery soon whoa boy
oh boy
I should have gone for the battery then
I got my old pal hoody go intra battery
thank you
get back up your leg up hmmm whoa I keep
forgetting that I can't ever stop laughs
like con sabe looking Oh doing the
twirly gig over there oh god oh god I
couldn't see I couldn't see nothing
I can't hear nothing ah man that's hard
that's hard it's hard on my voice oh my
god it really sucks I can't
well I guess if I can't hear that it
doesn't matter I can I can play this
with one ear what your phone off and
that means I'd be able to hear myself
and I wouldn't have to constantly be
yelling whoa oh my god that is so not
fair
getting a little brighter okay getting a
little brighter little brighter little
driver little brighter a little bit a
little bit of brightness in my life a
little bit of brightness in my life I'm
gonna be okay
I'm gonna be okay no you don't I'm gonna
be fine it's currently not nearly the
time I needed to be a clock run the
phone I'm trying to sleep
actually my mom is really miss have
cinnamon so worried that she might
actually come over like what's wrong you
want some more food that's my mom
impression I do when I'm sick it's the
best I can come up with thank you she's
bad Jesus I goodness garish oh goodness
gracious
okay okay hey oh well what do I tie oh
boy
I thought
I thought was was he there was okay to
what's happening hi stop that okay I
need to go for a battery soon or maybe I
don't because maybe it's almost time but
I'm not entirely sure I have oh he did
over my window okay that's what I
thought I saw he did open my window
which is bad but it's okay because I'm
gonna be okay yeah yeah yeah come the
most [ __ ] child on the face of the
earth and spinning my head around like
I'm in The Exorcist oh good oh come on
those two quick 4:15 God am i sorry
because this how are there to be one
more in there I'm gonna go for a battery
bank it's battery quickly
Oh load of baloney okay my voice is not
putting up to this okay I gotta beat
this I gotta beat this I know I can beat
it
I'm good at these types of games maybe
maybe if I do just spin my head like a
top would that be better maybe if I just
check from the back
because I can I can almost so can almost
always here when he's at the closet I
think this is working a little better
than what it was before
goddamn see that the squeak of the
closet doors is very distinct but if I
stay over here then I don't think I lose
my night-vision which is actually a
pretty good strategy because I could
keep my back to the plots door and for
some reason my night vision only goes
away when he's over there I'm getting ya
I've gotcha
and this is a little less movement to
check these main three than it is to go
the other way around I heard that yes
closet door is very distinct
hello Rudy okay there goes my light but
my seat the night the night the
night-vision does stay in this little
area what was it
okay those of lavender
we're fine I got distracted by other
noises well okay well nighty-night wall
99 wall nighty-night no no no he is
silent when he's at that window you have
to look he's absolutely somethin that's
already open completely freakin silent
not a single damn clue whoa
I heard that
yeah it really does seem like the goal
that the closet door squeak is
completely unique and that's probably
for a reason I do think that this is
probably better of the two strategies so
markiplier style doing it better than
anybody else can I be the king Oh God
did not hear that one probably cuz I was
squealing well I got to be like stay on
the window for just a little bit longer
because it's it's very it's very obvious
that he can sneak through even when I
think I see him at some times no
and yes sometimes no
I can always hear that I can always hear
it I've gotta just enough battery left I
think I'm gonna be okay
I think I'm gonna be alright all of you
pro level bogeyman players probably know
that this is the ideal strategy with
which to defeat the bogeyman no one is
going to be murdering me tonight thank
you very much mr. bogey mr. man
sorry you there so peeping in
far so good so far so good wouldn't 5:48
oh boy oh man whoo ah man I probably
shouldn't tempt myself to keep recording
like this even though my voice is still
recovering like I don't it's so annoying
it's one of those things that like gets
in your voice
not that that's a problem cuz maybe I
could just keep speaking from my bottom
range so thank you everybody so much for
watching I know there's another night
here I'm not sure how many nights
they're all are but thank you everybody
so much for watching I'm gonna finish
this up real soon and as always I will
see you in the next video where the
kapre bladder go